[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur phoenix
persönlich wir sprechen heute mit der
kriegs- und krisenregionen das zdf die
gerade erst für ihre arbeit mit dem
grimme preis für die besondere
journalistische leistung ausgezeichnet
wurde herzlich willkommen karen
eigendorf dankeschön dass ich hier sein
darf
sie machen ihren job jetzt seit vielen
jahren warum sind sie kriegs und
krisenregionen geworden also ich habe
mich dazu nicht bewusst entschieden dass
ich gesagt habe das möchte ich gerne
werden ich wollte immer schon
journalistin werden und als journalistin
hat es mich immer von anfang an in die
welt rausgezogen also sag mal ich bin
jetzt keine edelfeder oder begeisterte
filmemacherinnen sondern mich hat
eigentlich am journalismus er
interessiert etwas zu erfahren zu
erleben immer ein permanent neue dinge
mit neuen dingen konfrontiert zu sein
und hat das hat mich dann auch relativ
früh schon ins ausland gezogen und
irgendwann hat sich dann einfach die
situation ergeben bei meinem ersten
auslandsposten in russland dass ich in
einen krieg rein geraten bin und wenn
man mittlerweile
auslandsberichterstattung macht die welt
besteht eben zu großen teilen
mittlerweile auch aus krisenherden so
hat sich das irgendwie ergeben aber es
ist jetzt nicht so dass mich kriege und
krisen besonders anziehen kann sie jetzt
viele auszeichnungen bekommen unter
anderem den grimme preis mit der
begründung dass ihre reportagen
besonderen mut besondere transparenz
aufweisen und sehr empathisch sind aber
noch mal einen schritt zurück gerade am
anfang hatte sie damit vielen
widerständen auch zu kämpfen als kriegs-
und krisengebieten
im land meinen sie jetzt oder generell
ja auch im sender also
ich hab mal die frage gestellt bekommen
von einer zeitungs reporterin das hat
mich darauf gebracht darüber zu
reflektieren ob es schwierig ist als
frau in krisengebieten zu arbeiten oder
ob es eine besondere herausforderung
oder schwierig ist als kriegs- und
krisenregionen zu arbeiten und ich muss
sagen die größten schwierigkeiten sind
eigentlich liegen darin dahin zu kommen
weil wir haben es immer noch im sehr
männer dominierten system zu tun das war
als ich jung war natürlich noch viel
mehr männer dominiert und ist zu
schaffen als frau sich diesen platz zu
erobern
dass man an dass auch zutraut das ist
sehr schwierig gewesen und ich habe
damit ganz ganz vielen rückschlägen auch
zu tun gehabt und will das auch jetzt
ein bisschen so als meine aufgabe
junge frauen zu ermuntern zusagen macht
das einfach lasst euch nicht einreden
dass er das nicht machen können weil
ihre mütter seit oder
weil man euch als frauen vielleicht in
bestimmten ländern nicht ernst nimmt
nein es ist wichtig dass wir frauen in
der auslandsberichterstattung haben
widerstände in meinen berichterstattung
gebieten habe ich eigentlich relativ
wenige erlebt sie dann ja auch dass sie
in bestimmten situationen in afghanistan
einen vorteil haben wenn sie als frau
tatsächlich mit den menschen oder mit
anderen frauen kontakt aufnehmen wollen
beschreiben sie doch mal wo sehen sie da
auch ein vorteil also gerade in
afghanistan haben wir mit einem land zu
tun wo frauen weitgehend abgeschirmt
werden das war ja auch schon vor der
machtübernahme der taliban so also
gerade in konservativen familien ist es
so dass nicht die möglichkeit besteht
dass man mit den frauen reden kann als
man also wenn man zum beispiel wenn man
überhaupt die möglichkeit hat bei einer
familie eingeladen zu werden zu hause
werden normalerweise die frauen
rausgenommen und die männer reden mit
den männern und mit mir als frau dann
aber ich erlebe es immer wieder dass ich
als frau eben dann zugang zu den frauen
habe mit ihnen reden kann das ist
natürlich ein großer vorteil dann weil
ich die perspektive ja der anderen seite
auch mitnehmen kann und auch frauen
begegnen wir natürlich vertrauensvoller
als wenn sie mit einem männlichen
reporter ist zu tun haben wenn es um
bestimmte themen geht sie haben jetzt
mit zusammen mit ihrem kollegen
sebastian eben in der reportage gemacht
noch mal zum jahrestag der
machtübernahme der taliban wie schwierig
die situation ist und wie sich das auf
ihre arbeit auswirkt das schauen wir uns
einmal kurz gemeinsam an wir sind
verabredet mit dem stellvertretenden
taliban-sprecher billig
bevor das interview beginnen kann müssen
wir eine lange debatte führen denn der
taliban-sprecher möchte nicht mit einer
frau im bild zu sehen sein es ist das
erste mal dass ein taliban das verlangt
auch das ein zeichen dafür dass die
angebliche offenheit eher weniger wird
wir können ihr kein interview machen wo
sie mit der kamera reden ich bin
journalistin sie sprechen mit mir wenn
sie nicht mit mir sprechen wollen okay
dann gehen wir
[Musik]
doch der taliban-sprecher wer das
interview nicht platzen lassen
wir haben kein problem mit der
anwesenheit dieser frau
wir respektieren sich
ich habe auch kein problem mit ihren
fragen
es ist nur so dass ich mich nicht
besonders wohl fühlen wenn ich mit ihr
zusammen setzen
er gibt ihnen dann das interview betont
nochmal er respektiere ja frauen wenn
sie sich denn an die regeln halten wie
sind denn diese regeln jetzt ein jahr
nach der machtübernahme
also es ist ganz klar dass frauen einer
bestimmten kleiderordnung zu folgen
haben also sich nur verschleiert in der
gegend in der öffentlichkeit zeigen
dürfen daran muss man sich auch als
westliche reporterin halten und dieses
ganz klar dass taliban frauen natürlich
nicht auf augenhöhe sehen diese debatte
war ganz interessant weil es ist das
erste mal dass mir das in dieser form
begegnet ist weil als westliche
reporterinnen genießen wir natürlich
schon das privileg dass wir für die
taliban so eine art würde sagen drittes
geschlecht sind also die sehen ja nicht
ein problem darin dass unsere ehre jetzt
in frage steht sondern sie beziehen das
dann auf sich und diese forderung dass
er nicht mit mir zusammen im bild zu
sehen sein mag ist sagen wir mal eine
drastische formen dessen wofür die
taliban stehen also ich erlebe das auch
immer wieder dass in einem raum sitzen
und da sitzen nur wo männer und darum 20
30 männer und mein kollege ein
afghanischer producer ist ja auch ein
mann redet dann mit dem gesprächspartner
und dann ins bild gesetzt und spreche
mit dem und manchmal gucken die mir auch
nicht in die augen
so weit geht das aber ich hab da in der
situation war ich natürlich es per flex
als er sagte ich spreche nicht mit der
möchte nicht mit der reporterin in einem
bild zu sehen sein das machen wir jetzt
nicht so ich bin in die reporterin sie
reden jetzt nicht mit der kamera sondern
entweder mit mir oder ich gehe also ich
werde dann auch gegangen dadurch haben
sie den eindruck dass sich wirklich
drastisch jetzt nochmal verschlimmert
und
vielleicht auch gerade wegen des ukraine
krieges das so ein bisschen unterhalb
des radars passiert die situation in
afghanistan verschlimmert sich für
frauen ganz dramatisch und das läuft
natürlich im moment ein bisschen unterm
radar weil der ukraine kriegt natürlich
sehr präsent ist in unserer wahrnehmung
und natürlich für uns als deutsche auch
eine andere bedeutung hat als die lage
in afghanistan
aber was ich jetzt bei meiner letzten
bei meinem letzten besuch im juli was
ich gemeinsam mit meinem kollegen
sebastian eben da erlebt habe ist dass
die taliban eigentlich nichts von den
erwarteten
reformbemühungen auf die man ja zu
anfang gesetzt hatte dass er vielleicht
nicht ganz so drastisch gegen frauen
vorgehen oder dass sie nicht ganz
damals totalitär regieren sondern auch
versuchen andere gruppen mit
einzubeziehen in die regierung all das
hat sich als wunschdenken erwiesen auch
für sie persönlich war es ja so wo sie
waren in afghanistan als sie den anruf
bekam jetzt bitte in die ukraine da
steht ein krieg bevor dann sind sie hals
über kopf von afghanistan richtung
ukraine aufgebrochen sie haben ein buch
dazu geschrieben und zeigen wie der
krieg alles verändert hat und schreiben
kein ereignis hat sie in den fast 30
jahren diese als reporterin arbeiten als
so bedrohlich und so einschneidend haben
sie liegt kein anderes ereignis
empfunden für das leben das wir alle
gewohnt sind
wie nehmen sie die situation in der
ukraine jetzt ein halbes jahr nach
ausbruch dieses krieges waren
die situation hat sich natürlich für die
menschen in sofern
noch weiter verschlimmert als die zahl
der opfer ja permanent steigt und dieser
krieg ja immer weiter sich durch weite
kreise der bevölkerung frist muss man
sagen es gibt immer mehr tote es gibt
immer mehr schwer verletzte dass das
auch ein bisschen zu kurz kommt in der
berichterstattung ist die situation an
der front was eigentlich mit den
soldaten da passiert also da gibt es ja
situationen
da gibt es unglaublich viele opfer unter
den ukrainischen soldaten warum kommt es
zu kurz in der berichterstattung ja das
möchte die ukraine natürlich auch nicht
dass wir darüber so viel berichten also
wenn wir zum beispiel gelegenheit haben
an der front zu drehen werden wir
natürlich meistens in einheiten
geschickt wo die situation nicht so ganz
gefährlich und so dramatisch ist man
begründet das zu recht natürlich auch
mit unserem eigenen schutz aber die
richtig schlimmen situationen kenne ich
nur aus gesprächen zum beispiel ich habe
einen engen kontakt zu einem arzt einem
ukrainischen arzt der lange in
deutschland gearbeitet hat und jetzt als
militärarzt arbeitet und was der metall
weise beschreibt wie sie die soldaten da
aus der situation herausholen mit
schwersten verletzungen gar nicht mehr
in der lage sind alle schnell zu
behandeln weil einfach auch die ärzte
dafür fehlen das ist schon sehr
dramatisch wie sich dieser krieg
entwickelt hat für das land
interessanterweise erlebe ich aber den
widerstandswillen der bevölkerung das
ist ja das was bei uns in deutschland
auch zu anfang des krieges großes
erstaunen hervorgerufen hat alle hatten
ja geglaubt dass russland die ukraine
relativ schnell besetzen und die
regierung entmachten könnte der
widerstandswillen der ist immer noch
sehr sehr stark also die menschen wollen
nicht unter russischer besatzung leben
sie nennen das poco das heißt putins
krieg warum putins krieg es ist ja
bislang jetzt nicht erkennbar dass
ja es in der bevölkerung in der
russischen jetzt nennenswerten wirklich
einen aufstand oder widerstand gibt oder
was das war ihre gedanken als in diesen
titel ausgewählt haben ich habe mich
dafür entschieden dass putins krieg zu
nennen weil das russland was wir heute
erleben und das ist was wir heute sehen
ist putins russland also ich war ja
selber von 1993 bis 1999 korrespondentin
in russland und habe das land in einer
phase erlebt wo ist das erste mal
öffnung gab das erste mal
dass langsame entstehen an der
zivilgesellschaft sicherlich findet
putin heute sehr großen rückhalt in der
bevölkerung den winter nicht wirklich zu
quantifizieren wissen weil es ist halt
keine freie gesellschaft viele menschen
haben das land verlassen die menschen
die im prinzip für demokratisierung
eintreten sind entweder hinter gittern
oder tod oder im ausland also das was
wir jetzt erleben in russland mit
vermeintlichen rückhalt ja das muss man
natürlich mit einem großen fragezeichen
sehen weil erstens mal haben die leute
nicht wirklich genug informationen zur
verfügung und glauben teilweise diese
negative die putin verbreitet und putin
hat diese gesellschaft und dieses land
in den letzten 22 jahren eben mit seiner
entourage auch sehr stark geprägt
deswegen nenne ich dass putins krieg
glauben sie dass es so etwas geben kann
wie einen aufstand gegen punkten oder
hat er es geschafft mit alexei navalny
noch den letzten die letzte starke
stimme sozusagen jetzt auch noch zu
verbannen das ist sehr schwer zu sagen
also wir haben es ja im moment mit einem
land zu tun dass verschwunden ist hinter
einem eisernen informations vorhang wir
haben ja auch hervorragende kollegin die
idee hat ina ruck sicherlich als eine
der besten reporterinnen und
auslandskorrespondentin mit ihr gut
befreundet und wir tauschen uns auch oft
darüber auf und sie auch sie hat
schwierigkeiten das einzuordnen denn wir
können nur mutmaßen wir können mutmaßen
darüber was wirklich im kreml passiert
ob es auch eine gewisse erosion
innerhalb dieses macht zirkus gibt
aber im moment ist widerstand gegen
dieses regime lebensgefährlich sehr sehr
schwierig ich sehe im moment wenig
ansätze bis kaum ansätze das ist
wirklich zu seinem einem
regierungswechsel von der straße
getrieben kommen könnte also dazu ist
dieses regime einfach zur totalitär und
zu autoritär organisiert auch
deutschland hat jahrelang die situation
ja muss man jetzt im nachhinein sagen
falsch eingeschätzt wie erklären sie
sich dass gerade weil sie auch so lange
im land geliebt haben wie erklären sie
sich dass es
ihnen gelungen ist ein bild von sich zu
zeichnen was nicht der realität wie wir
sie jetzt ganz deutlicher sehen
entsprach
das ist sicherlich eine eine mischung
aus phänomenen die dazu geführt haben
dass wir das so falsch eingeschätzt
haben also das wichtigste ist natürlich
dass wunschdenken mit russland gute
beziehungen haben zu wollen weil
deutschland hat sich und sieht sich ja
auch in einer besonderen verantwortung
und schuld als verursacher des zweiten
weltkrieges wir haben in russland und
russland ist ja auch ein wichtiges land
global mit dem man eigentlich eine gute
partnerschaft braucht also wunschdenken
auf der einen seite dann auch mangelnde
kenntnis also in deutschland
interessiert man sich nicht wirklich für
den osten europas es gibt ja wenige
journalisten auch zum beispiel die
diesen weg eingeschlagen sind dass sie
gesagt haben ich interessiere ich mich
jetzt für russland oder studiere
russisch und lerne die sprache also wir
haben ein bisschen auch verkannt was in
dem land passiert was in dem land auch
gerd
denn was man von außen erlebt ist doch
immer was anderes als wenn man es von
innen betrachtet und dann hat putin ist
natürlich als
trainierter geheimdienstler sehr gut
verstanden
mit diesen bedürfnissen und dem
wunschdenken der deutschen zu spielen
also ich erinnere mich daran wie
begeistert sein auftritt 2001 vor dem
deutschen bundestag aufgenommen wurde
woher ungewöhnlicherweise für einen mann
seiner position in deutsch geredet hat
er spricht ja auch fließend deutsch und
hat auch enge beziehungen zu deutschland
das war ein zeitpunkt der sei die lage
im land ganz anders aus wir haben da
gedacht das land öffnet sich und wir
nähern uns an und es gibt ein
gemeinsames europäisches modell aber das
gemeinsame europäische modell
sah in putins augen anders aus als in
unseren denn da war bereits der umbau
dieses staates zu
einem autokratischen staat der
eigentlich nichts mehr ist als die
ermöglichung eines großen klaus von
ressourcen denn das ist das wofür die
regierung putin steht war bereits in
vollem gange sagen sie sich im
nachhinein sie hätten vielleicht noch
stärker kritische berichte machen müssen
noch mehr darauf hinweisen müssen also
hinterfragen sowie sich jetzt auch noch
mal in ihrer eigenen rolle
nein ich hinterfrage mich nicht in
meiner eigenen rolle weil ich habe in
den redaktionen immer dafür geworben mir
war das von anfang an klar und das war
nicht nur mir klar sondern das war im
prinzip allen reportern klar die sich
mit russland befasst haben und sich mit
dem land auskannten dass dieses land
keinen guten weg gehen wird und worauf
das hinführt aber man ist mit diesem
mit dieser form der berichterstattung
nicht durchgedrungen also das war sehr
sehr schwierig wir haben russland immer
gerne im programm gehabt als das
spektakulär schöne land tolle sibirien
reisen
[Musik]
reportagen aus dem eis die schöne wolga
armut vielleicht noch als thema aber
sagen wir das was sich politisch in dem
land entwickelt hat damit ist man in der
berichterstattung zu wenig im programm
präsent gewesen sonst hätten wir ja
nicht dieses debakel auch erlebt dass
zb die tatsache dass wir so auf
russisches gas gesetzt haben und nord
stream 2 durchgesetzt wurde es wurde er
von allen die sich in russland auskennen
die sache ernst zu nehmen sind
kritisiert und darauf aufmerksam gemacht
dass das ein großes problem werden
könnte und das fällt uns jetzt vor die
füße aber so wie sie sagen nicht
durchgedrungen
wahrscheinlich war auch ein moment die
korona pandemie als einfach nochmal
natürlich noch mal eine ganz neue
situation auftrag mit einer situation
die so raumgreifend war das zum teil
auch themen aus dem ausland in den
redaktionen so nicht durchkamen
beschreiben sie mal wie haben sie die
zeit empfunden der kona pandemie die
natürlich verdrängt hat
das ist nicht nur die korona pandemie
sondern ich glaube das habe das selber
erlebt dass ihn würde ich mal sagen den
letzten
sechs sieben jahren und das ist in der
korona pandemie noch einmal ganz
deutlich zu tragen gekommen wie ein
bisschen den blick für die krisen dieser
welt verloren haben und durch corona
haben wir uns natürlich sehr sehr darauf
konzentriert wie gehen wir selber mit
dieser krise um also wir sind ja selber
im prinzip dann zum krisenland geworden
das ist auch eigentlich liegt in der
natur der sache dass man sich dann auch
im journalismus damit beschäftigt das
sehe ich jetzt auch nicht als
kritikwürdig an aber ich glaube was wir
jetzt erleben und zuletzt erlebt haben
mit afghanistan und auch der ukraine
außenpolitik ist wichtig und
außenpolitische berichterstattung ist
wichtig und da sehe ich auch eine
kernaufgabe des öffentlich rechtlichen
fernsehens darin dass wir das machen
weil wir können das gut wir haben gute
leute wir haben die ressourcen
damit müssten wir uns viel stärker auch
in der öffentlichkeit präsent zeigen und
da nicht so ein bisschen manchmal das
gefühl wir erklären da so ein bisschen
eigentlich unsere eigenen kapazitäten
unter den teppich sie waren ja auch in
butter und haben die kriegsverbrechen
mit eigenen augen gesehen
sie schreiben wir in buxheim war der
kann nicht anders als den eigenen blick
auf den krieg von grund auf zu verändern
es ist genau das ja wo auch natürlich
viel wirklich drüber gesprochen wurde
vielleicht erinnern wir uns noch mal
gemeinsam daran wie war es als sie vor
ort waren
das kam ja sehr überraschend
diese situation in butter dass wir da
einen zugang bekommen und es kam mir
auch für die ukrainische seite relativ
überraschend die russen haben sich
zurückgezogen und auf einmal war klar
was da passiert ist es war ja vorher im
prinzip besetztes gebiet und keine
informationen drang wirklich nach
draußen und hat man auf einmal gesehen
ja dort liegen massenhaft menschen tot
auf der straße
dort wurden menschen entführt gefoltert
auf offener straße hingerichtet dort
wurden frauen vergewaltigt also die
situation nicht mehr ich habe eigentlich
ehrlich gestanden die situation in
butter als sehr bedrückend erfunden
empfunden aber noch viel schlimmer war
es für mich hab mir auch andere orte
angeguckt es war nicht der einzige
bianca zum beispiel oder ob ihn
das fand ich auch das ausmaß an
zerstörung noch mal im zusatz zu dem was
man den menschen angetan hat als
besonders bedrückend und schlimm da hat
man einfach gesehen das russische
militär hat witten in einem wohnkomplex
bomben reingeschmissen und es war alles
zerstört und man sah ich habe da
menschen erlebt die zwischen den
trümmern
herumliefen und versucht haben noch
irgendwie etwas zu finden was was was
sie noch daran erinnert was man ihr
leben war
die ganze grausamkeit dieses krieges und
die kriege sind immer grausam aber die
grenzenlose attacke auch auf die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung ja auf
kindergärten spielplätze auf
krankenhäuser auf zivile wohl
wohngebäude das ist einfach durch
butscher und durch das was man da erlebt
hat noch mal besonders klar geworden und
auch das grausame vorgehen der
russischen armee also wir haben es ja
hier mit einer armee zu tun die gar
nicht mehr nach den gesetzmäßigkeiten
von ordnung funktioniert und das sind ja
teilweise marodierende plündernde banden
also ich hab mir selber ein bild davon
machen können in alpinen und bianca da
haben mich ukrainische soldaten durch
wohnungen geführt wo man noch sehen
könnte da haben die russischen soldaten
gehaust anders kann man es nicht sagen
da standen noch einkaufswagen von den
supermärkten diese geplündert haben
leere alkoholflaschen also dass ein
soldat dass soldaten sich in den
wohnungen einrichten und sich da sinnlos
betrinken und einfach auf leute schießen
die auf der straße herumlaufen das ist
ja eine form der kriegsführung
ja man einfach nur als
zivilisationsbruch bezeichnen kann und
doch ist genau in dieser schwierigen
situation ja ihre aufgabe sich nicht
vereinnahmen zu lassen weder von der
einen seite noch von
desinformationskampagne noch von der
anderen seite wie schaffen sie das und
wie schaffen sie es auch immer wieder im
zusammenspiel natürlich mit dem
deutschen zuschauer da ja wirklich für
sich selbst auch so sagen das ist das
was das ich hier sagen kann von dem ich
davon ausgehe dass ich an dieser stelle
nicht von einer seite vereinnahmt werde
also ganz wichtig ist natürlich dass man
bestimmte professionelle standards
einhält für mich ist das allerwichtigste
als augenzeuge vor ort zu sein mir
wirklich ein bild von dem zu machen was
da geschieht und nicht einfach
irgendetwas zu übernehmen was
kolportiert wird das ist natürlich
gefährlich und manchmal auch schmerzhaft
weil man muss dann immer vor ort
wirklich nah rangehen und dann muss man
natürlich das was man dort erlebt
entsprechend einordnen also ich gebe
mein konkretes beispiel
sind ja sehr viele menschen in bhutan
und bianca interviewt wurden von
journalisten haben teilweise grauenvolle
geschichten erzählt man muss das immer
abgleichen man kann ich jetzt einfach
jede geschichte kolportieren wenn eine
frau sagt ich wurde vergewaltigt da muss
man das schon auschecken und manchmal
erweisen sich solche checks auch als
richtig ich habe selber schon
situationen gehabt wo ich menschen
interviewt habe ich gedacht habe das
werde ich jetzt nicht senden weil ich
das nicht für glaubwürdig halte man muss
auch im hinterkopf behalten dass man es
natürlich mit traumatisierten menschen
zu tun hat die geschichten nicht immer
100 prozent so erzählen wie sie denn
wirklich sich ereignet haben aber
dadurch dass dieser krieg so sehr gut
dokumentiert ist kann man ja auch sachen
abgleichen also man kann ja gucken ist
das wirklich so gewesen dass in dem
moment die russische armee dort war oder
ist es wirklich so gewesen dass dort
leichen in den strassen gelegen haben
also es gibt ja satellitenaufnahmen es
gibt handyaufnahmen das erleichtert es
für uns das auch klar zu machen
nichtsdestotrotz ist man als reporter
immer auch subjektiv weil die frage ist
ja wo gehe ich hin was gucke ich mir an
auf was richte ich meinen augen merck
und man darf und sollte dem zuschauer
nicht das gefühl vermitteln dass wir so
eine art berichterstattung roboter sind
durch das land fährt und einfach
aufnimmt was was da passiert sondern wir
gehen natürlich gezielt an situationen
anzeigen gezielt dinge sprechen
bestimmte fragen auch an mitmenschen
und das transparent zu machen ist sehr
sehr wichtig in ich glaube man muss dem
zuschauer einfach klarmachen oder müssen
unseren zuschauern klar machen ich bin
hier als journalistin mit einem blick
auf die dinge und ich komme zu der
überzeugung ausdehnen und den gründen es
hilft natürlich sehr dass sie die
sprache sprechen und sprechen russisch
sprechen auch okay
sie haben russland lange gelebt sie
haben es uns erzählt wie haben sie die
zeit in erinnerung
eigentlich als sehr sehr spannende zeit
also das war mein anfang als
journalistin als als als
als reporterin und russland 1993 war ein
land in dem war unglaublich viel möglich
was sonst eigentlich undenkbar ist also
es hat sich eigentlich so viel für uns
geöffnet ist es gab kaum grenzen man
konnte in gebiete fahren da war davor
noch nie ein westlicher journalist man
konnte mit menschen reden die haben noch
nie ein interview gegeben man konnte
sich einblicke verschaffen
reisen
sie hat sich auch jeden tag neu beweisen
also immer wieder neuen
herausforderungen
gegenüberstehen dass das fand ich
wahnsinnig spannend und ich habe das
auch persönlich als als eine
fantastische zeit erlebt weil ich tolle
menschen kennengelernt habe ich finde
auch die russische kultur sehr sehr
spannend unsere kinder sind ja auch in
den ersten jahren in russland groß
geworden also ich muss auch sagen ich
fand es fantastisch zu erleben was meine
tochter einem russischen kindergarten so
erlebt hat und mitgenommen hat an kultur
ja
an eindrücken auch deswegen ich behalte
die zeit als sehr sehr positiv
im gedächtnis sie manchmal geschrieben
das sind eine sehr liebevolle betreuung
für ihren sohn philip julius gefunden
haben der einem nicht heilbaren krampf
leiden
und dass moskau so die beste zeit in
seinem leben wohl gewesen sei
warum
ja das liegt daran dass natürlich die
betreuungsformen für uns dort viel
besser waren also wir haben als wir nach
moskau ging relativ schnell eine
wunderbare frau gefunden
natascha die philipp
als kindermädchen betreut hat wir waren
ja beide berufstätig und sich einfach so
liebevoll um ihn gekümmert hat und wir
haben viele menschen in russland erlebt
die ohne irgendeine ausbildung zu haben
also natascha weiß keine ausgebildete
krankenpflegerin oder pädagogin die sich
aber ganz ganz toll dieser aufgabe
gewidmet hat und das war in den ersten
jahren für uns mit dieser großen
belastungen die das war so meine tochter
ist ja nur ein jahr jünger war also auch
ein baby und philipp auch in dem zustand
des babys und mit zwei babys
als berufstätige eltern klar zu kommen
das wird in deutschland zu dieser zeit
und ich vermute mal auch in der jetzigen
zeit kaum möglich gewesen
wie haben sie es geschafft nach dem tod
ihres sohnes dann die kraft zu finden in
ihrem ja wirklich sehr aufreibenden job
weiterzumachen
ich habe mir danach auch erst einmal
eine auszeit genommen also ich hab nach
philips tot ein dreivierteljahr gar
nicht gearbeitet und bin dann langsam
körper also auch nicht direkt wieder in
in den beruf zurückgekehrt
ja das ist natürlich ein
schicksalsschlag der das leben
dramatisch verändert
aber gewisse konstanten sind natürlich
geblieben und sind auch wichtig und die
konstante ist ist auch mein beruf und
ich war auch sehr froh dass ich beim zdf
dann da wieder anknüpfen konnte wo ich
aufgehört hatte nämlich als auslands
reporterin
und ja ich nehme das mit und das prägt
sicherlich auch ein stück weit die art
meiner berichterstattung dass ich selber
in meinem privatleben das erlebt habe in
einer so dramatischen situation zu sein
aber wie gesagt das leben geht weiter
man nimmt das mit aber
alle konstanten die man hat sei es
familie oder auch job sind wertvoll
jetzt haben sie so eine erfahrung als
kriegs- und krisenregionen und die frage
die sich aufdrängt zum schluss ist
natürlich wer oder was kann diesen krieg
in der ukraine stoppen
ich sehe im moment wenig anhaltspunkte
dafür dass wir diesen krieg dass dieser
krieg schnell endet weil es auf
russischer seite
überhaupt keine bereitschaft dafür gibt
sich an den verhandlungstisch zu setzen
und jeder krieg und auch dieser krieg
wird irgendwann am verhandlungstisch
enden müssen man wird irgendwann zu
einem irgendwie friedensvertrag kommen
müssen
ich denke
putin muss in die situation versetzt
werden dass er sich genötigt sieht sich
an den verhandlungstisch zu setzen dass
er sieht dass er die gewinne die er
erzählen wollte nicht erzielen kann das
macht sich jetzt im prinzip schon in den
letzten sechs monaten klar dass in
diesem krieg wladimir putin der große
verlierer es hat nichts erreicht von dem
was er heute ganz im gegenteil er hat
eigentlich sehr sehr viel verloren er
hat die beziehung zum besten verloren er
hat sein land in eine wirtschaftliche
katastrophe gestürzt er hat es isoliert
zu einer art paria staat gemacht und
auch im prinzip sein eigenes regime sehr
geschwächt das bittere ist die frage wie
lange wird es dauern
dass putin so weit ist dass er einsieht
dass
er sich an den verhandlungstisch setzen
muss und da sehe ich leider dass der
preis dafür für die ukraine
möglicherweise sehr hoch sein wird denn
sie bezahlen müssen denn dieser krieg
hatte ich ja zu anfang gesagt fordert
immer mehr opfer
zerstört ja auch immer mehr in dem land
und ist auch ein globales risiko also
nicht nur was die ernährungssituation in
vielen ländern an betrifft sondern wir
sehen jetzt auch die situation im
kernkraftwerk suggeriere das ist auch
ein risiko für uns in europa also das
ist das größte kernkraftwerk europas da
im prinzip mitten in einem krieg geraten
ist das ist eine große bedrohung sie
waren anfang september glaube ich wieder
hin wir sind gespannt und erstmal
herzlichen dank für das gespräch fragen
auf danke dass ich hier sein durfte
[Musik]